vous parlez d'un tout autre sujet de
tout compte fait sur france 2 qui
s'était intéressé au business des
données personnelles vous savez ces
petites choses là ces téléphones qui ont
toutes nos informations
eh bien on connaissant simplement la
géolocalisation d'un téléphone portable
sur une période donnée
il est possible d'établir un portrait
très précis d'un individu qui peut
intéresser les marques
je n'imaginais pas tout ce qu'on peut
comprendre sur votre vie en suivant
simplement vos déplacements on va
d'abord regarder une journée typique
c'est l'objet unique
bah oui tu de visite à peu près 400 fin
sans l'appeler à sélectionner et bah tu
vas faire tes courses on n'a pas souvent
une fois aucun faux c'est pas le plus
près celui ci ça effectivement ces
informations sur les lieux où il va
faire du sport sur son domicile sur son
lieu de travail vont être moulinet par
un logiciel qui va en déduire sa
personnalité très distingué monsieur
ouverte
ils sont partis ce travail de déductions
plutôt intrusif les marques le ferai
vous comprenez mieux pourquoi les
données de géolocalisation sont une mine
d'or pour l incroyable business donc
finalement on est un petit peu la proie
quazar sans le savoir et me dit vous
trouvez ça bien bon bah oui je trouve ça
génial mais déjà de nous mêmes en fait
on le dit c'est qu'à chaque fois quand
on dit qu'est ce que tu présentes au
téléphone je sais pas j'ai tout
là-dedans barème après faut pas
s'étonner que les gens y viennent
piocher dedans
bah oui m'enfin on n y crois quoi voilà
mais c'est très pratique du conte à des
publicités que c'est un peuple
évidemment les pubs le grand chose à
cacher par contre j'ai une petite
anecdote une petite astuce si jamais
certaines personnes qui sont un petit
peu gêné par les pubs justement dans les
téléphones à la pomme vous nous l'avez
donné à la
c'est la miss fait notre monteur qui
nous a qui nous apparaît madras gms
bravo là vous allez dans confidentialité
il ya un onglet publicité tout en bas
parce qu'ils étaient tous deux chez pour
que les gens reprennent après les tricks
prenez votre téléphone vous allez dans
confidences en général général alors oui
confidentialité il faut que les lotos le
temps que les gens le fassent
après on peut aussi de mettre sur
twitter c'est la confidentialité
tout tout tout en bas il ya publicité
vous y aller et là vous cochez un petit
onglet qui vous permettrait d'avoir
ainsi si les publicitaires limité ça
donnerait moins réduit
c'est génial des pubs un peu moins
céline les astuces de mymy
[Applaudissements]